here's an integral that we can solve by
substitution
in the exercise where this is given they
give you a substitution let x
equals 4 sine theta and so we're going
to use this
in order to evaluate this integral now
once you um have a substitution you've
got to obviously start by working out
all the pieces
that are going to fit into here based
off of this so some easy examples first
you can see that
there are x squares here and i've got an
x so i'm going to need to work out what
x squared is which is not hard it's
16 sine squared theta
at the same time if i want to do the
substitution i'm going to need to know
the derivative
here so that's dx on d theta
is for cos theta so you can see that dx
there is going to substitute for a 4 cos
theta
d theta okay so far so good
now i can start to put these pieces in
over here so what do i get
well the integral of and you've got 16
minus 16 sine squared theta
up on the top that's what we just
determined over there on the bottom
you've got
4 sorry take that back 16 sine squared
theta because it's just another
x squared and then instead of dx i'm
going to write 4 cos theta
d theta so there you go i've done all my
substitutions
so far so good but we can do a lot of
simplifying here for starters what's
underneath this
square root sign here is a
16 cos squared theta using the
pythagorean identity
then you've got a 16 sine squared theta
still
there times 4 cos theta
all right so you can see a few things
here
that 16 under the square root is going
to become a 4. together with that 4
there'll be 16 and there's a 16 on the
denominator so i'm going to cancel
all of those coefficients that's kind of
nice
secondly i've got the square root of cos
square theta which properly speaking is
the absolute value of cos theta
and then you've got another cos theta
there so you've got
cos squared on the top
sine squared on the bottom okay
now you have to think about what you can
do with this to make it better and
there's an identity
a very simple identity again the
pythagorean identity which will help us
here
on the top that cos squared we can write
as 1 minus sine squared
the reason why that's useful is because
it'll let us cancel very simply
with what's on the denominator i'm going
to get
1 on sine squared minus
1 and all of that is integrated with
respect to theta
okay now this is good this is better
than what we started with
i know how to deal with that one but
that's one over sine squared is a little
more finicky
so how do i deal with it well um
you could do this if you if you can't
see the result straight away um you
could do this by
t results we've learned how to do
integration by t results
but it's not complicated enough to
really warrant that if you can see that
what i can do here is divide the
numerator
and the denominator by cos squared now
if i do that
the reason why that'd be useful is it
turns the top into sec
squared and it turns the bottom into 10
squared
okay now this is nice because sec
squared
is the derivative of 10 so this sort of
fits into
a reverse chain rule and this is really
sec
squared times tan
to the power of negative 2 and then of
course we have a negative 1 there
right so what you've got here is a
function raised to a power
and you've got the derivative of that
function on the outside so you can see
that you would get this result if you
differentiated something and use chain
rule we're going to do it in reverse
okay so what do we get here this is
going to be equal to
you take that function you raise its
power by 1
but you're also going to divide by that
new power
so you're going to get negative tan
theta
to the power of negative one and then
you should have divided by the
derivative of the inside function which
is sec squared so it just
disappears it cancels there you go then
you've got minus
and that minus one turns into a theta
okay so what you've got here this is
actually negative
cot theta minus theta
this is good but our original question
had nothing to do with thetas
oh sorry i should have um should have
added the constant in there
um the original question had to do with
x's right so just like
i put the get got rid of the x's and put
them in terms of thetas
i should do in reverse to get it back in
terms of x's
so the question is what can i do with
these well the theta is easier to
resolve
if you have a look at x equals 4 sine
theta i can make
sine theta equal to x on 4 by dividing
both sides by 4.
and that gives you this result theta's
sine inverse of x
on 4 in a restricted domain anyway
so therefore i can use that to
substitute for this theta
but what i do with this cot theta that's
a bit of a pain well
we can still work with it if we come
back to this line
sine theta equals x14 now again in a
restricted domain we can consider theta
as an angle in a triangle specifically a
right angle triangle
so if i stick theta over here if sine
theta is exon 4 that means that
the opposite side on the hypotenuse
sine oh sorry opposite on hypotenuse
that should be x on 4 right
now that makes my pythagoras this side
over here 16 minus x
squared so if i want cot theta
theta that's going to be not opposite on
adjacent which is
tan theta but adjacent on opposite
this over that that's cot theta so
therefore i can substitute that in
that'll be negative the square root of
16 minus x squared
all over x and then i said that i was
going to substitute theta for
sine inverse minus sine inverse
of x on 4 plus your constant and there
you go